what we found was interesting when we
made this story that was really at its
core was a story about a son trying to
looking for his father's approval in
Adam was the fact that we had three men
who had their sort of at the leadership
team level who had dealt with these
issues that both Lee and cliff and
myself all lost our fathers either at
really early ages I my dad died when he
was 38 I was four when I lost my dad so
we all have this sort of like repressed
kind of issues around dads that we felt
like which again as a reflection of our
creators that felt like I was kind of
being mirrored a little bit in the
relationship between that Adam and
Marcus dad you should look at this no
you look I warned you not to join the
cog what did you do dad I told you don't
go outside here the COG will hunt you
down again what did you do you shut up
and look when I think of Gears of War I
think of chainsaws
I think of shotguns I think of gore
but there is another side to gears a
softer more story-driven side from
Marcus and Dom's Battlefield camaraderie
to the many tragic deaths that tugged at
our heartstrings Gears of War has always
embraced personal emotional storytelling
still when I interviewed Gear's creator
Cliff Bleszinski and an event earlier
this year he told me something I never
quite expected to hear gears at the core
of it all as much as it's a shooty
shooty bro game about you know chainsaws
and lizard men it's always been about
that issues to hear the series outspoken
creators so openly cite dad issues as
the defining theme of the entire
franchise was a bit surprising not
pretty gory heroism were
adrenaline-pumping action but dad issues
so when I went to visit the Coalition at
their Vancouver studio last month to see
an early build of Gears of War 4 I kept
that in mind I wanted to find out what
it's like to take the reins of a hugely
revered franchise and build a team
around a project fraught with
potentially insurmountable expectations
but I also wanted to ask about what
clique had said I wanted to know how
Gears in spite of its brony characters
and bloody shooting have become a story
about family dad would need your help
I'm all done helping you and then
talking with the team I quickly
discovered the catalyst for both could
be traced to the same guy
I'm Rod Fergusson and I'm the studio
head of the coalition what can I give a
war for rod Ferguson has been with gears
from the beginning in 2005 he actually
left Microsoft to join Epic Games and
work on gears full-time he served as the
original game's executive producer a
role he maintained and expanded for the
entire original trilogy so when
Microsoft bought the franchise away from
epic and recruited a new studio to
create Gears of War 4 rod was a natural
choice to head up the project even if
his future team had no idea of what was
about to happen
so before I showed up it was called
black tusk and it kind of been
reimagined a couple times as a studio up
here in Vancouver they did free to play
stuff and they or they were working on
free to play stuff is working on connect
stuff and then they started working on
their own IP of a triple-a game I'm just
prior to my arrival Phil decided to sign
here's award get it buy it away from
epic and he was looking first to you and
the at that time when they were working
on their triple a came here they were
working on Unreal Engine 4 so they had a
better a year and a half of Unreal
Engine 4 experience so bringing years
here made a lot of sense and so when I
found out about it in December 2013 then
I was like and they were like oh you're
available and I'm like yeah and they're
like I just like make gears again looks
like absolutely and so yeah it was
pretty interesting as a Friday it was I
guess it was a Friday in January they
announced to the studio hey that thing
we've been working on we're not working
on that anymore
and because we got Gears of War so they
were all excited and then I showed up
the Monday yes so they had that a
weekend to process it before I showed up
yeah I was here day one when when we
started working on kids war when rod
came and we started talking about the
ideas of what the story could be and
what kind of enemy factions we wanted to
do
along with that there was those baby
steps of the beginning of the creative
process so like I think the first
meeting I had with Chuck and rod was
talking about story and what kinds of
story rod was interested in telling and
what ideas we had it progresses pretty
quick you know when you have a good
trade of connection and you've got sort
of like a fertile property like yours
wore to work from we started moving
pretty quickly into sort of like a
skeleton for a story on the wall and
discussing different enemies and and
mission ideas as the team found its
footing and began to embrace its new
role the time came for black tusk to
claim a new identity one that would
brand the studio as gears rightful home
and so I felt like black tusk didn't
have that affinity that I don't really
wanted it to have and so looked at
renaming and and sort of looked at what
else could we be it really felt like I
wanted to tie to the lore but I still
have another meaning to it and that's
what I liked about the coalition because
there's obviously the coalition of
ordered government's from tomorrow you
know that game when you look at what our
studio is which have the definition of a
coalition as a diverse set of people
working on a common task or a common
goal and that's really what we all are
Ferguson may have been confident in his
team but the coalition still faced a
daunting series of obstacles most
importantly they had to figure out how
to make a Gears game from scratch and
they had to do it while balancing their
own ambitions with fan expectations we
were worried about was just people not
feel like we were capable of kind of
owning the franchise that we didn't know
what it took to take to to make a Gears
game and so I almost think we maybe in
hindsight maybe we over invested in that
in a sense that that kind of played a
little bit of Defense I know she's going
to say like okay job number one is do it
right before we do it different you know
we really have to prove ourselves as the
coalition we really need to respect the
franchise and respect the fans so we
want to make sure that what people
really feel like the first thing I want
to hear out of their mouth is it feels
like it gives a wargames
watch out for the quilt
and we've wooden working on this project
for three years and and in the first
year it was equal parts creative
exploration and sort of like analysis
and a whole lot of work that I don't
think people know about where we we made
sure that as we ported gears to to
unreal for that we build tools to make
sure that you know down to the pixel the
mechanics were working the same as they
did inside the gear 3 in addition to
coping with the technical demands of
bringing gears to a new console
generation the coalition also needed to
find a way to inject new ideas without
disrupting the classic formula major
additions like the clothes cover combat
system came together over time but even
smaller details could sometimes be a
battle you know if you talk to Kirk our
art director like that Kate's hat is one
of them you know like she was designed
without a hat but what's the story of
Kate's had so you know Kate was a great
character
we all loved her she actually has a
shaved head on one side on her knees and
it's kind of really cool ponytail what
you do see and I think we all kind of
fell in love with her and then rod he
was at a cafe and found this girl they
thought was very interesting and so I
was like I really like that and so I
took I kind of creepily did the like I'm
using my phone but I'm taking pictures
kind of things I take a picture of her
and so then I brought back to Kirk and
I'm like I want his hat and he was like
of course I wanted to accomplish that
and it's not too hard to draw a hat on
top of a concert great piece so we did
it and you know I was a little torn
myself but then I started hearing
murmurs amongst the team but not
everybody loved the Hat some of the team
you know kind of revolted against in
there coming to me like Kirk I don't
like the Hat why did you put the Hat and
go up something no rod wants to explore
let's do this let's live with it for a
little while another person coming to my
office like are you sure about the Hat
and then I'm like why do oh no no I'm
just a messenger I'm just hearing not
everybody loved to have it I'm like I'm
like really I'm like I really love the
Hat so finally I said look we're gonna
bring it to e3 if we get a bunch of
pushback then we can talk about it but
if people's accepted that I'm moving
forward trying to stay alive true but if
it survives and most don't it finds a
way to change you know over time you
know it's just like a person you know
that you end up caring about it really
became her and now to go honest I can't
imagine her without the Hat is so funny
through iteration experimentation and
compromise the coalition gradually honed
a creative vision for Gears of War 4 and
in the process the team's hard work
began to pay off in some cases sooner
than expected
we were expecting to have to defend a
lot more and and convince people a lot
more and and show them like hey look
it's a Gears game but pretty quickly
like even early on I mean some of the
first demos we're getting like yep
that's the gears game and you're like oh
wait like you're already convinced oh no
and then once we got that and got that
reassurance then we've been pushing the
innovation to go like okay let's make it
new and fresh you are walking this very
fine line of well if you make the game
too much like even through tears game
throws we're each reading a little
ground but if you stray too far then
you're returning the franchise now how
do you walk that line is it possible to
meet fans expectations well that's
that's what we're attempting to do is to
walk the line I talk a lot about the
idea of betrayal of expectations rightly
you need to portray them somewhat
because if you give them exactly what
they're expecting and there's nothing
interesting and if you portray them too
much that's not the game they wanted and
so you have to find that line and that
this is our attempt right and I think
for some people I hear it already in
some people when they look at you know
let's take our 83 2016 demo people go
like some people feel like maybe we're
too close to the original and now that
we're bringing robots I get like that
doesn't belong in their franchise that's
crazy robots is nothing so they feel
like we've gotten me on the other side
of it and so with every fan is if they
have different expectations you know and
about what they want from a Gears of War
game so we're trying to give enough
innovation to show that we have places
we can go with this and where we want to
take the franchise but we want enough
people to feel like we respect what came
before and then we understand it and we
know how to build it with the gameplay
coming together and the team learning to
reconcile ambition with expectation
Ferguson was finally able to focus on
the aspect of gears that attracted him
to the project in the first place
when here's 1 2 & 3 like I was again I
was in the every recording session I was
reading and editing every script and so
there was a part of me that was in that
I was working doing you know with with
Josh on Gears two we were doing writing
till 8 a.m. to go in at a 9 a.m.
recording you know like there's like
very active in the process of making
those stories you know games are an art
form something that we're all proud of
that we put a lot of time into that it's
it's that time I think to where things
that can really a story in a game can
last just the time that's why I mean the
games is to tell stories and so that's
why no studio head should probably be
going to LA and doing the voice-over
recording for the actors right like in
the fact I'm like okay everybody I'm
gonna disappear for a week now because I
got to go record voices for a week they
and normally that doesn't happen the
more I learned about the creative
process driving gears for the more I
realized how much of it was shaped by
Ferguson's passion for storytelling to
him the writing isn't an afterthought
it's not window dressing to him
the writing is the most meaningful
aspect of game creation in part because
it allows them to explore issues that
affect him personally I like experiences
that affect players you know and if you
walk away is why I'm not making match
three games on my phone you know it's
like it's I want something that when you
come away from it you have you feel
something that when and the Maria Cena
gives to and you know at comic-con in
2000 people raised their hands that they
cried at it and the Dom scene and gears
3
you know that I'm effecting people to
agree that they want to get tattoos on
their arms and they and they're
reconnecting with distant family members
and like that that's that's what
motivates me as a game maker it's having
the the ties for the past ve not just
there as fanservice but being an
important part of the story and being
something that is crucial to sort of
like the characters relationships and
exploring themes of family and stuff
like that that was a that was a big deal
for us
what we found was interesting when we
made this story that was really at its
core it was a story about a son trying
to looking for his father's approval in
Adam was the fact that we had three men
who had their sort of at the leadership
team level who had dealt with these
issues that both Lee and cliff and
myself all lost our fathers either at
really early ages I my dad died when I
was 38 I was four wouldn't lost my dad
and so and so we all have this sort of
like repressed kind of issues around
dads that we felt like was again as a
reflection of our traders I felt like I
was kind of being mirrored a little bit
in the relationship between Adam and and
Marcus
I was able to see to a cat Marcus
now go then to live
good
to have
we're accustomed to thinking of intimate
indie games like gone home and that
dragon cancer as personal explorations
but what if one of the largest triple-a
franchises of all time was in part a way
for its creators to work through
life-altering trauma to nurse wounds
that may never fully heal for Rod
Fergusson and Gears of War for that
certainly seems to be the case Cliff
Bleszinski it turns out was right all
along and it's even true now like I mean
I'm older now I'm 48 and I've got a 22
year old son my son is the same age as
JD essentially right and so the
relationship that JD has DeMarcus is in
some ways I don't ever have that kind of
an adversarial relationship with my son
but it does make you think more as a
creator like I'm not a 20 year old kid
trying to make a game about a
six-year-old man and a 20 year old son
right I'm I'm somebody who's actually
living through that and knowing what
it's like to have a 20 year old son and
the kinds of things that they bring to
the table and are thinking about and
worrying about and so it's interesting
to see that sort of stuff again I think
all games in some way whether it's
subconsciously or not or a reflection of
their creators
you